한 달에 거의 한 100개 업체
엄청난 겁니다 100개 업체 정도가
매달 이제 폐업을 하고
[음악]
있고네 안녕하세요 비사 아입니다 저희
bsn이 저번 주에 뭐 7일 동안
빌딩 계약을 여섯 권을 했는데 어떤
빌딩들이 매각이 되는지 저희가 이제
어떤 걸 중계했는데 참고가 되실 것
같아서 영상을 찍게 됐습니다 일단
여섯 건 중에네 건이 이제 강남에
있었고 나머지 두 건은 이제 마포쪽
쪽에 있었습니다 매매 총 금액이
485억 정도 됐고 500억이 조금
안 되는 금액이었습니다 평균 거래
금액으로 봤을 때는 한 80억 정도
그래서이 중에서 당장 건축 행위가
필요한 노후화된 건물이 신축이 한 건
있었고 리모델링이 두 건 정도
있었습니다 나머지는 좀 노화 됐긴
했지만 유지할 만한 건물 신축이나
리모델링 한지 얼마 안 된 그런 건물
2년 전만에도 사실 빌딩 시장이 너무
호황일 때는 되게 노후화된 건물 건축
행일 해야 되는 건물 비율이 되게
높았어요 거의 제가 봤을 때 한 7
80% 이상이었습니다 요즘에는 워낙
이제 자재 가격도 많이 오르고
신축이나 리모델링 할 때 행정적인
절차라는 이런 기관들도 더 오래
걸려서 신축이나 리모델링 하는 분들이
줄어든 거 같습니다 그리고 앞으로도
건축 자재 가격이라는 인건비라도
이런게 계속 상승될 것으로 예상이
돼서 이런 비율이 좀 더 낮아지 지
않을까 그래서 얼마 전 기사도 봤을
때 건설업 폐허 건수가 되게 많이
늘어났어요 한 달에 거의 한 100개
업체 엄청난 겁니다 100개 업체
정도가 매달 이제 폐업을 하고 있고
신규 오픈하는 건설업을 등록하는
건수가 그때 기사 보니까 한 70%
감소했다 그러더라고요 그래서 그만큼
되게 건설업 경기가 매우 안 좋은
상황 같습니다 그래서 저희도 지금
건설업을 하고 있지만 무늬라는
신축보다는 리모델링 무늬가 좀 더
많아져 고요 아무래도 지금 좀 건설업
경기도 좀 많이 안 좋아진 거
같습니다 불과 2년 전만 해도 매도인
우의 시장이었습니다 그래서 막 건물
갑자기 계약한다고 했을 때 가격을
올리거나 계약 자리 안 나오거나 계약
자리 왔는데 갑자기 가거나 뭐 그런
사례가 되게 많았는데 심지어는
계약금을 받았는데 그냥 배액 배상하는
사례도 워낙 많았어요 그때는 워낙
사는 사람이 많아서 근데 지금 같은
시장에는 매도인 우의 시장이기 때문에
금액 협상이라는 이런 조건들을 좀
좋은 조건에 할 수 있는 그런 기회인
거 같습니다 그래서 만약에 현금을
가지고 계신 분이라면 지금 빌딩
투자하기에는 좀 굉장히 좋은 시기라고
저는 좀 생각이 되고 지금 연준에서
원래 이제 금리를 올해 뭐 세 차례
이상 내리겠다고 했는데 지금 상황이
많이 안 좋아졌잖아 그래서 물가도
지금 좀 안 잡히고 있고 아마 금리
인하가 올해 진짜 안 될 수도 있고
아니면 진짜 올해 말에 가서 될 수도
있는 그런 확률도 있기 때문에
지금까지는 되게 빌딩 시장이 안
좋아요 본격적으로 금리를 내리기
시작하면은 그때부터 거래량이 좀 많이
상승할 것으로 좀 예상이 됩니다 만약
현금 가시고 계신 분이라면 좀 오래
이렇게 좀 지켜 봤다가 진짜 괜찮은
거 나왔을 때 투자를 검토해 보시면
좋을 것 같아요 지금도 어찌됐든
금리가 아직까지 좀 높은 상황이고
지금 애매한 건물 샀다가는 나중에
팔리지도 않고 진짜 원금 손실이 날
수도 있거든요 정말 확실한 매물이
나왔을 때 투자할 만한 되게 좋은
시장이라고 좋는 생각을 합니다 그리고
이제 빌딩 가격이 오르는게 원화가
하락 요인도 되게 크거든요 그래서
오래 의 좀 기사를 보니까 올해 원화
가치가 한 6.8% 정도 내려갔다고
합니다 그래서 만약에 내가 10억을
가지고 있으면 올해 지금 4월 달이죠
그 4개월 만에 거의 한 7천만 원
정도 손해를 본 거예요 그래서 원화
가치는 이제 계속 떨어지고 있고 지금
인플레이션은 되게 심화되고 있고
그래서 여러분들이이 돈을 해지할 만한
자산에 좀 넣어 놔야 되는데 그게
이제 부동산도 그 중에 하난데
그중에서도 좀 공급의 제한이 있고
수요가 많은 데에다가 돈을 넣으셔야
돼요 예를 들어서 집이다라고 하면
누구나 다 좋아할 만한 그런 집
있잖아요 뭐 압구정 현대라는 반포
자이라는 이런 뭐 원 베일라지 크로라
막 이쪽에 많이 수요가 몰려 있잖아요
그런 지역에 부동산을 사던지 강남
빌딩이라는 아니면 성수동 빌딩이라는
아니면 용산 빌딩이라는 이런 확실한
곳에 투자를 하셔야지 인플레이션
해지가 됩니다네 지금 워낙 가이
하락하는 부분도 되게 좀 크기 때문에
돈을 잘 가지고 있는 것도 중요하지만
인플레이션을 해지할 만한 자산에
어디에 투자할 것인지 좀 고민해
보시면 좋을 것 같습니다 오늘 좀
이런 매각된 사례로 좀 간단하게
설명을 좀 드렸는데 작년 1분기보다는
거래량이 되게 많이 늘었어요 거의면
체감상은 한 2.5배 정도 계약을 더
많이 했었던 거 같고 올해 지금
1월부터 한 4월까지 3천억 좀 안
되게 중계한 거 같습니다 그만큼 되게
거래가 많았었고 작년 1분기 때까지만
해도 담보 대출로 빌리면 한 6 7%
정도 나왔거든요 요즘에는 그래도 대출
금리가 좀 많이 내려 가서 한 4%대
진짜 잘 나오면 한 3%대 중반도
나왔어요 그 정도로 좀 금리가 많이
내려가서 올해는 작년보다 좀 빌딩
거래가 많이 됐는데 대부분 다
거래된게 보면은 강남이나 마포 뭐
성수가든 좀 주요 지역에 많이 몰려
있었고 예전 같은 경우에 이제 건축
행위들도 많이 하긴 했는데 요즘에는
좀 완성돼 있는 거 그런 것도 거래가
좀 많이 됐다 뭐이 부분 참고해
보시면 좋을 것 같습니다 그래서 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하고요 다음 시간에
뵙도록 하겠습니다 감사합니다 l
[음악]